[Musique]
jean pagé fait une entrée remarquée dans
le monde du journalisme sportif
les commentateurs et des analystes
expérimentés en 1976 trois ans après son
embauche à radio canada il fait partie
de l'équipe de tonnerre affectés à la
couverture des jeux olympiques de
montréal
ce seront les premiers de 12 années où
il agira mais une fois comme chef
d'antenne et bienvenue à ce deuxième
reportage sur les 14e jeux olympiques
d'hiver de sarajevo yougoslavie les jeux
olympiques de los angelès à atlanta pour
jeux olympiques d'hiver de nagano entre
les jeux jambages une chôme pas voici
maintenant les nouvelles du sport de
radio-canada animateur régulier du butin
des sports de france soir et il sera
tout autant matinale pour commenter les
sports à la radio médium qui lui avait
ouvert les portes de la profession dans
sa jeunesse à chicoutimi dans les années
1980 il agit aussi fréquemment comme
descripteur de la formule 1 au patinage
artistique
et parfois sans jamais avoir peur du
ridicule
ils se jettent aussi dans l'arène
sportive et l'aja comme pour cette
corrida organisée en marge du mondial de
soccer qu'il décrit au mexique et on le
découvre aussi en nombre de gala autant
aviles a chanté sur un vélo
[Musique]
on sourit
k confondre ses collègues quenneville
garneau et arsenault j'ai 3 47 euros
bravo
[Applaudissements]
la soirée du hacker monde sonne à radio
canada c'est toutefois la soirée de
hacking qu'il gagnera durablement la
faveur du public pendant 17 saisons ils
assurent l'animation de l'émission phare
de radio canada
merci en studio il reçoit toujours avec
tact joueurs entraîneurs et analystes et
même les premiers ministres chrétiens
bouchard moins d'un an après le
référendum de 1995 jean pagé animateurs
apprécié du public
ils montrent huit fois de suite sur la
scène du gala metrostar pour y cueillir
les honneurs et deux fois sur celle des
jumeaux jean pagé a aussi utilisé sa
notoriété pour sensibiliser les hommes
au cancer de la prostate qui l'a frappé
tôt en 1995 à 49 ans porte parole de
procure il sera l'un des initiateurs de
la marche du courage qui amasse chaque
année des centaines de milliers de
dollars pour la recherche
une belle tradition qui a pris fin hier
soit aussi celle de la soirée du hockey
en 2002 après un demi-siècle à l'antenne
la soirée ceux à qui ne sera plus
produite par radio canada jean pagé
quitte la société d'état après 30 ans
pour devenir l' arbitre des débats
sportifs de 110% à tqs
mais avant c'est lui qui aura eu la
tâche douloureuse de tirs a duré
spectateurs de la soirée du hac en vous
disant pour la dernière fois au revoir
monsieur aujourd'hui jean pagé affaissé
au revoir pour la deuxième fois